discrete random variables this very big
heavy phrase right what do we mean by
each of these 3 terms hopefully we've
been looking at enough tonight time now
that even if you don't have like a
technical definition for it you could
explain what each of these bits mean
let's start with the last one it's the
easiest one when we say variable why do
we say that senator Kent's right okay so
we have some numbers we want to measure
we put the variable in place of the
number mainly because the number can
change right variable it can vary what
do we mean random this one does have a
very specific meaning and it's not the
one where usually when we're like well
how random that's not what this random
means what does this random mean they
want to suggest
yeah well very good so multiple outcomes
I think the key part of it is that
without bias part right so if you've got
like a loaded die okay or you're talking
to people and they're more likely to
give one answer than another then it is
not truly random okay so that's what we
mean by that all options are equally
likely except for whatever the
probability density function tells us
and we'll have a look at that in a
second last one we just one discrete
what's me discrete so mainly its its
whole numbers things that are separate
okay by the way not to be confused with
discrete that has a double a does anyone
know what that means yeah like Shh
discreetly right so people don't know
okay
different spelling same pronunciation is
completely different words all right so
let's have a look at 20 you've got that
graph in front of you and it shows a
discrete probability distribution so
have a look at the bottom axis of the
graph for me right 1 2 3 4 5 6 so these
things cannot mix if it wasn't a
discrete random variable what kind of
random variable it'd be if all of the
things mixed together
very good continuous is the opposite of
discrete okay so we want to calculate
the expected value of this distribution
so we've got 20 part now let's just
remember what's the like fancy way of
saying the calculation of this we use
this weird Greek letter does anyone
remember which one it was the Sigma very
good we use the Sigma because the Greek
letter Sigma is equivalent
it stands for what some very good you're
adding up a bunch of things what are we
adding up to work out expected value
what are we adding up there's two pieces
that go into this and remember
yeah go ahead say okay yeah very good so
the X values and we usually write them
like so like the eye is 0 1 2 3 4 etc so
these are the X values now the Y values
just have a look right what are the Y
values here it's actually not labeled a
y-axis we usually call it Y but what is
it in this case okay yeah probability P
of X right so that's going to be the
probability of that particular score
turning up there's one thing missing
from my segmentation can you tell me
what it is it's actually at the
beginning when you see this do you
remember when you say this is sum of a
bunch of things right you actually have
to specify like where do you start and
where do you end okay you would have to
specify I equals we usually start from
zero and then in this case how many
scores are there there's one two three
four of them so I go from zero up to
four this is not to be confused with
like what these X values are are not
zero one two three four what what are
the values that are relevant for me have
a look two three four and five very good
so that's what these numbers are going
to be let's go ahead and actually do
this so we're gonna have our four
different products here so the first one
you told me was to what am I going to
multiply it by thank you it's
probability zero point one and then I'm
going to add that to do this again for
every single one of them alone okay so
I've got three is it zero point two they
just go up in steps out there okay so
that's kind of convenient for us and now
is a good time if you haven't already to
reach for your calculator because we're
going to go ahead and calculate what
this expected value is I'll give you a
sec to get to there or has anyone
already got it I think I calculated for
beforehand so please go ahead you've got
to make sure you do this right but you
should get four once you've got that
right so this is the expected value now
remember it because we're going to turn
the page and use this to answer the next
question so have a look over and I'm
just going to
just if there's two of you who can see
this maybe one person turn their page
the other person stay on the original
page because we'll also need that papi
what does it ask it's a bit of a
mouthful would you expect the medium to
be greater than less than or equal to
the expected value of this distribution
okay there's a lot there right put it
your hand if and no one puts up their
hands that's fine but I just want to
know put out your hand if you could say
I know how to find the median that's the
first thing you're asking for in this
distribution any takers
yeah that's I just I'm not gonna ask you
I just want an indication all right
that's fine okay thank you let's all try
and work out how this is calculated what
what is median like this is papi it's
the middle middle number the middle
value right so what we're looking for is
where does the median occur now it's a
bit tricky when you've got a probability
distribution because normally we would
say something like there's five people
right and you want to say okay which one
it has the median height so what would
you do you'd arrange them let's give
them a tall haircut you'd arrange them
somewhat this guy's just has a big head
that's why they're taller you'd arrange
them in higher order right and then you
just say which one's the middle one okay
now have a look at this probability
graph there's no like bunch of people or
a bunch of items and then you can just
count along right all we've got is
probabilities okay but we can work this
out nonetheless by calculating and where
you've got Part B written there
can ask you to write down the phrase
cumulative cumulative probability so
this is very similar to cumulative
frequency if you remember calculated up
all the way back in like year seven and
eight what we're going to do is we're
going to add up the probabilities and
let them accumulate as we go further
along okay so draw me a little table and
on our table we will need one two three
columns they don't need to be huge
they're three columns the first column
is going to be our particular x-values
now you already told me what they were
they are two three four and five okay in
this table were also going to have the
probability of those X values so I'll
just write P for probability
and we have that written now in our
expected value calculation yes so it's
0.1 0.2 and so on okay
now this last one is the cumulative
probability so just like we've
cumulative frequency we're just going to
add everything as we progress down the
table so for the first row I only have
one probability to add it's there 0.1
okay as I write the next one I'm
including all of the probabilities
before so it's 0.2 and all the previous
ones so what will the cumulative
probability be here so you're put 3
that's it now at this point I'm going to
add my next probability and all the
previous ones so 0.6 very good and then
the last one gives me one which it
should why is that it's it's what is one
mean in this context yeah the better add
up to 1 that means I've got a
comprehensive list of all the things
that could possibly happen the total
probability is 1 if I add everything up
together okay so there's the end of our
table now how do we use this the meeting
is supposed to come like you told me
halfway like in the middle right so what
would the middle probability be it'll be
zero point hmm think carefully like
halfway through like the position would
be 0.5 the way through does that make
sense
if the final if the final person is 1
the final person is 1 then the middle
person should be 0.5 ok so what I'm
going to do because it's discrete I have
to go up in steps right so let me ask
humor me okay by this value have I
gotten to 0.5 year no I haven't by this
value have I gotten to 0.5 year no I
haven't but once I cross into here
somewhere in here I get to 0.5 in fact I
go past it don't I okay so this value
here this is the median okay it's
wherever what's the first moment the
first instant that you pass that 0.5
threshold might be worth turning that
down it's on when we pass
the cumulative probability being 0.5
it's a bit weird that it isn't exactly
0.5 you're like it's not this one and no
it's not that one the whole point of
discrete random variables is that you
can't say it's in between your one or
the other okay because you haven't
gotten to it here it only happens on the
next one can we use this to answer our
question look back at the question it's
a bit of a mouthful right it says I
actually have the book here mmm
whoops way to go would you expect the
media to be greater than less than or
equal to the expected value what's our
answer it is exactly equal to we've
worked out expected value here and then
here's our medium okay so so far so good
you can say you can write down if you
like
it is equal it is equal